before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
so folks around here know that I like to
try to some degree cosplay as the doctor
whose work I'm reviewing at least in the
modern era
I'll see what I can throw together for
this look but I'm not growing a mustache
[Music]
yep we have a reveal of the costume for
shurigatwa the 15th doctor still
officially designated
um as well as Ruby Sunday His companion
I will be talking almost not at all
about her outfit because I don't have a
high investment or much to base anything
that my thoughts are on it's
it's fine I will say the two of them
paired together it almost looks like a
photo shoot focusing on gotwell which is
what I want to talk about I don't know
how long this video is going to get
probably one of the shorter ones that'll
be on the main Channel but like I gotta
talk into this because the thing is some
people might go like why are you going
on about just the costume reveal like
why would you spend time on this because
the costume is often indicative of some
aspect of the doctor is it something you
can necessarily parse in advance no not
necessarily but once you've seen the Run
of each doctor again especially in the
modern era but also true backing classic
there's something about their outfit
that is informed by their personality
whether it be something that is just
kind of closed off and and just very
controlled like the Ninth Doctor whether
it be the 10th doctor looking a little
bit Dapper but the ties loosen and he's
got the running shoes whether it be the
11th doctor being completely
anachronistic the 13th Doctor being just
kind of bubbly chaos in her look and so
like this stuff does matter and there
are things to talk about so let us talk
about this look
oddly enough the thing that I was kind
of most surprised by were that the boots
complemented the rest of the outfit and
I'm gonna call them boots in the uh
image where he's just by himself they
they look more like shoes but then we
get a little bit of a more complete look
at them in the image where he is where
the doctors with Ruby Sunday and yeah
those go a little those go high enough
to look like boots and there's more of a
soul to them than I thought there would
be so like those seem fairly practical
but they're also you know designed they
look like they match this outfit they're
not something that's thrown together it
looks very put together it's a little
bit of a retro look
um it actually I'll back that up I was
gonna say it feels kind of 70s it
actually doesn't but it does feel like
something that would be put together
today maybe to evoke or um show
influence from the 70s or that era of
fashion and it does feel much more like
a fashion statement it overall then I'm
used to seeing from the doctor now part
of me does Wonder
if having this pulled together a look
this fashionable of a look because even
when the doctor has had a look that's
like yeah that's like that's a good look
it's still not cut it's still not
necessarily something you think current
fashion about like the 10th doctor
probably came the closest but you know
even him you know with the tight
pinstripe suit like he still stood out a
little bit and I'm assuming shooting got
to his will as well but it stands out
more on a oh are you going to a photo
shoot kind of way and again I wonder if
that is a direct indication of what we
could expect from his
um personality you know whether it's
going to be sort of charm maybe even
aloof a little bit or if it's going to
be something in contrast to the
personality is he going to deliberately
look more pulled together than he is to
try and compensate
I don't know I'm not actively
speculating or uh claiming it'll be
either one but I'm floating
possibilities because that's what's fun
to do about this a couple of other
little details he has uh some jewelry he
has the necklaces I don't know if
there's anything actually on there the
image that uh was put out over Twitter
which is how this was announced which
like okay before I get back to the
jewelry
it's a little bit irritating to me that
the stuff is drip feeding largely
through Twitter and so like
on the one hand I get it first of all
chibnol was actually very closed off and
didn't drip Feed Us much at all uh in
between series and one could even argue
that might have been part of what hurt
the anticipation of later series after
series 11 is he didn't do much to
contribute to building excitement but
you know he approached it how he
approached it and so I'm not going to
say that I would have preferred silence
but that having been said like these
tiny drip feeds of like here's the new
companion well here's just an interview
we got we got with the new doctor on the
red carpet here's the costumes you know
here's an image of Neil Patrick Harris
you know just these little tiny drips
not a lot of context when they just kind
of happened and on the one hand like I
also expect a lot of this just has to do
with let's put it out formally before it
gets leaked and if you don't have like a
big cumulative stuff to present all at
once like you know the costume of the
companion it's cetera like all in one go
then yeah drip feeding it to avoid
having it leak which is I I still will
contest I think shooty got to his
announcement and the reason we found out
about that in a red carpet interview was
because
um they knew it was about to leak so I I
get that there is only so much control
um RTD has over you know what's going to
work and if he tries to just be like no
we'll keep it for a surprise a lot of
the stuff's just going to come out
anyways and so again I'm not saying it's
bad this way of approaching it it's just
you know
I had other stuff I wanted to do with my
weekend but I have to slot this in but
anyway so coming back to the jewelry
one of them looks a little bit like it
might be a medallion or a pendant or
maybe even a small Cameo or something
the the image is such that it looks like
it's just blank but it might the image
might not be high definition or might
not be zoomed in enough to be sure what
that is not that I'm going to attribute
like massive
um conspiracy kind of theory to what it
would be but because like is he'd be far
from the first doctor to have jewelry
the 12th doctor had Rings 13th doctor
had her her joined together earring
stuff you know it's it's fine it has
jewelry it's fine and also it helps
um give a little bit
um a more sort of texture is the wrong
word but just something to break up the
solid orange of the shirt it's a nice
touch again it feels very much informed
by not just a costume designer but a
fashion designer and maybe part of my
sense of that is just the way that uh
he's posed especially when he's paired
uh with Ruby Sunday
but the other thing that I alluded to at
the very beginning he's got a mustache
which like
we kind of knew from the one tiny clip
we've gotten of him as the doctor where
he goes what the hell is going on here
like he had a mustache
um it's so I I figured it was coming but
it's just kind of interesting to think
we haven't ever had a doctor
who had much in the way of facial hair
as part of the standard look
like we saw Matt Smith with a beard a
fake beard but like we saw that and
David Tennant had The Sideburns Sideburn
I got sideburns oh really bad skin but
you know proper facial hair just like as
being part of the look just being
something that's always there not a
one-off and not kind of and I feel like
sideburns are the most innocuous form of
facial hair that's new and again it
feels like it contributes because it's
not just that it's a mustache it is a
well-groomed mustache now that doesn't
necessarily reflect on like that the
doctor is grooming it it's actually one
of the things that threw me off when
Matt Smith ended up growing a beard in
uh that um I think was day of the Moon
because I remember thinking oh given
that David Tennant like regenerated with
The Sideburns already there I kind of
just assumed that the facial hair that
um time alerts have is just whatever
they regenerate with it just stays that
way
um so having Matt Smith actually grow a
beard kind of threw me off a little bit
um but it is kind of my assumption that
you know he regenerates and that's what
it is and it may or may not actively you
know grow and be something he has to
maintain but if that's what it's setting
up as again it's it's pulled together it
looks maintained it looks
um I was gonna say manicure that's
freaking Fingers
um it it just looks like it is something
that maintenance there we go it looks
like there's maintenance that is put
into it no but I also said maintain
that's just the same word again okay I'm
rambling I don't have that much to say
but as a look I it wasn't what I was
expecting well I say that I didn't know
exactly what I was expecting but I saw
that I was like oh
okay which to be honest has been kind of
my response to most of the Doctor Who
costume reveals so uh to sort of
backtrack by the time I got into Doctor
Who tenant was already Doctor Who
so or the doctor I'm just rambling at
this point I'm tired it's actually kind
of late in my day and I'm trying to cram
this in give me a break but um you know
I saw the costume reveal for Matt Smith
which actually made me a lot more
comfortable about him as the doctor
because when he first got interviewed
when his casting was announced he was in
an outfit that made him look you know
like a knockoff uh David Tennant in
Christopher eccleson's costume almost
but then when I saw his actual costume
you know with the bow tie and the tweet
it was like oh okay that is different
and Peter Capaldi's initial reveal where
he frankly looked like a magician Jody
Whitaker's reveal which I actually I
felt like I had a bit to say about
because it was so thrown together and
mismatched it was kind of just fun to
pick apart this one is so pulled
together and so uh such a complete look
that it's again it's a little bit odd
um I guess I don't think of the doctor
as being that pulled together and if
this one is it makes me more curious as
to how that is reflective or in contrast
to this doctor's personality
and we're ways off from finding that out
but
yeah it's growing on me I the the more I
look at I'm like okay
okay it is also the kind of look that
makes me wonder if we'll get alternate
looks because like David Tennant had two
suits he had the blue he had the
Pinstripe even though the Pinstripe
became a little bit more iconic
um capali had a bajillion variations
usually with a different shirt or uh or
sweater or jumper if you want to get uh
you want to get British about this but
uh you know there's that
um and
you know Matt Smith went through
multiple revisions longer coat sort of a
bringing in of purple
um Whitakers didn't really change but
again I feel like part of that was
because it was
it was so singular
as a look like with Matt Smith his
various looks are kind of relatively
distinct but that bow tie remained you
had something to ground you and with
Capaldi you always had a coat in the
same vein as all the rest
um even though there were some variants
there as well there's usually one thing
to sort of stick to and then the rest
can shift around it Whitaker's whole
look was so
um just pulled together in these random
bits that it was like what would you
even change other than
the primary color of the shirt which
they did change they had a blue they had
a blue one they had a red one this one
I'm looking at this and going I don't
know what you would
change I don't know what you would keep
um and then carry over to a revised like
a reviser an alternate outfit I guess
maybe change the shirt and keep the suit
or keep the shirt and alter the the
jacket and the pants I don't know I'm
kind of curious we'll see though as I
said I wasn't bowled over by this I
honestly really liked uh what occurs
costume revealed because it felt like it
was revealing a fair bit about uh her
and how she was gonna tackle it this one
it's a little bit harder for me to pin
down on that level but the more I look
at it it's it's growing on me
and I am still very much looking forward
to seeing what shootikatwa does I've
eaten up way more time than I thought I
would talking about this but we'll wrap
it up there
because I want to have dinner and relax
or try to I don't relax much I gotta
work on that anyway what did you think
of this costume whatever your thoughts
are drop slowing down in the comments
let's talk about it patrons what pays
the bills and enables me to do this my
for my living I can talk
ah any amount that you're able to help
is a great assistance even if you can't
like share subscribers help me out
there's other things that I do links to
those uh other projects Etc are down in
the description don't worry too much
about it though what I really want you
to remember is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula
Tarak the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters imudelki the oatha Boyd katoria
toyololi Becky Sparks for nabilax the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Castro
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what you doing there
[Music]